[Musique]
85% des français ont déjà essayé de
tirer sur un joint
et vous oui j'ai essayé alors ça fait
quoi je préfère soutenir la viticulture
française dakar bonne soirée 85% des
français ont déjà ici la drogue et vous
ont jamais essayé mais je serai une
tente rien n'a rien ouah vous n'avez
jamais alors essayé de faire un petit
peu de cocaïne non marijuana lsd non non
l'image des noms plenel mans 85 % des
français ont déjà essayé la drogue et
vous vous êtes déjà essayé la drogue non
les perruques voilà ça je savais salut
ça va bien merci
tu fais quoi là je cours non mais là ça
si tu fais là peu flou c'est quoi ça en
interview les drogués envie à ok voilà
une interview que les drogués que les
plus gros gros drogué de paris après en
fait on prend cette interview et on le
mène directement au commissariat
désolé parce que je suis français je
suis brésilien parler en brésilien vous
inquiétez pas on a dès la 3e' ok pour
moi c'est destructeur surtout c'est des
scooters destructeur des scooters par sa
couleur par rapport à les scooters j'ai
très bien compris des scooters mais par
rapport à quoi
bah à la santé déjà mais quel type de
scooter et diama non on line hockey au
ps comme hervé hamon son bilan 85% des
français ont déjà essayé la drogue et
vous
des halles est à tu parlais pas français
non mais pas le dire depuis le début là
j'ai fait ma question j'ai parlé pendant
45 secondes et tu sais maintenant que tu
me le dis ait choisi ses mots je me
casse
[Applaudissements]